you
you
hey I'm Pete I'm going to talk to you
about a library for creating user
interfaces that we call react and we
open source this at Jas conf us a couple
months ago and we got some kind of
sarcastic responses on Twitter a little
bit of snickering that kind of thing
we weren't really communicating what we
were doing so I'd like to talk to you
today about the design decisions around
react what we're doing differently than
other frameworks and kind of the
implementation that lets us make these
decisions and make it really fast so
it's not a tutorial it's not an
introduction you're not going to learn
how to build react acts today but you
might be able to use some of the stuff
that we've discovered in your own work
so I ask that you please just give it
five minutes some of the stuff that I'm
going to say flies in the face of some
established best practices but we found
that there are certain best practices
that deserve to be challenged so meet
react it's a library for creating user
interfaces specifically we render your
UI and we respond to events a lot of
people think of us as the V and MVC
maybe we're the controller to really
depends on how you use it but we try to
play nicely with your stack whatever it
may be so for example we're not
opinionated about how you fetch data
people use us with you know backbone or
whatever you use for managing your data
client-side so I'm going to talk to you
about kind of the initial principles
behind react which is all about building
components then I'm going to talk about
the design decisions that we made that
make react a little bit different from
other frameworks and finally I'm going
to talk about the implementation and how
we're able to make our implementation of
this framework really really fast
so I'm going to start with building
components not templates if you want to
think about this cynically we're talking
about mixing markup and display logic
and a lot of people completely disagree
with that so this is a much sure if you
can read it but this is kind of what
react code looks like this is from our
to-do list example on the home page
react is org it's all about building
reusable components that know how to
render themselves into the DOM
um but like I said I'm not going to go
through this line by line because this
is not a tutorial this is about design
decisions but we all like separation of
concerns right this has kind of been a
fundamental tenet of building apps on
the web ever since like the PHP
pocalypse of 1999 where we were putting
my sequel fetch row in the middle of our
table rendering code but let's talk
about what separation of concerns
actually means we're talking about
reducing coupling and increasing
cohesion coupling and cohesion they're
very they're two very important
principles of software engineering
here's the definition I pulled off of
Wikipedia about coupling and it's the
degree to which program modules rely on
each of the other modules now that's
kind of like a fluffy definition but
more concretely if you want to implement
a feature or fix a bug and you make the
change to one module be it like a class
common j/s module function a packet of
functionality how often do you have to
go to other parts of your code base and
make changes in order for it to work and
these sorts of cascading changes are
symptoms of coupling and that's what
makes software hard to maintain cohesion
is somewhat related as well and that's
the degree to which elements of a module
belong together so if you've heard of
the single responsibility principle
basically grouping related functionality
into modules and not putting extra crap
in there you know the kind of the
witness' test is like does this class
make sense or does this function make
sense or is it doing a lot of stuff and
can you refactor it into other pieces so
I think that templates encourage a poor
separation of concerns and it's not just
templates specifically it's anything
that tries to augment the Dom or HTML
with some sort of functionality to make
it better at building apps so I think
angular directives also fall into this
and it's not just client-side either
it's some server-side systems as well
like Jinja and kind of traditional
templating solutions now how can I
possibly make the argument that this is
a bad separation of concerns right
you've got your display plate code in
one place like your template and you
have other code in other places that
does that do different things now
normally your controller and your
they are tied together with something
called a view model and some some
frameworks actually the controller is
almost the view model so you pull some
data out of your database or with like
an AJAX call or something and you
construct a data structure that looks
something like this
so if I wanted to show a product grid
with the example that everyone uses
which is alternating row colors in some
templating systems you have to add a
table row color attribute to your view
model and we say that that's fine
because it's a view model it's not the
model and it's not the view it's in view
model now the problem is this tightly
couples your controller to your template
so if I want to make a change to how I
render those row colors while it feels
like I'm making it change the template
there's an implicit dependency between
the template and the controller because
they both agreed on that template row
color attribute in my example so you
actually have to make cascading changes
throughout your modules so it's not real
decoupling and I think that the display
mod the display logic and markup are
inevitably tightly coupled so if you're
building apps on the web that manipulate
the Dom you have to figure out where in
the Dom you're going to change and what
parts need to be updated and what nodes
are receiving events but the good news
is is that this is highly cohesive logic
so the the JavaScript code that that
drives your UI and the markup that
displays it to the user are both doing
basically the same thing they're
handling user events and the rendering
data to the to the user so I would like
to argue that templates separate
technologies and not concerns it's not a
real separation of concerns the
separation of technologies you're using
to implement the same concern and
unfortunately the way that we're doing
this today they tend to be deliberately
underpowered so I'm going to show you a
couple of examples of what I mean by
being underpowered and the first
technology I'm going to pick on is
handlebars sorry Tom so first of all
handlebars is an excellent
implementation of templating it's really
fast it's really easy to understand and
it drops right into a lot of different
frameworks but it's an implementation of
kind of a classical way you build
templates so they
actions you have available are fairly
primitive so the the easiest one to
think of is partials if you want to
reuse a template you tend to use
partials and a partial basically takes
one template and embeds it in another
template now that embedding puts all of
the puts that template in the parents
scope so if you want to make a change to
a child template or a partial you need
to track down every single call site
that uses that template and make sure
that you don't break anything because
there isn't a strict contract between
the partial and the template that
includes it this is going to be a
recurring theme of my talk another
example of an underpowered technology
and here is each it's like oh it's like
doing functional programming but you
only have map you don't have filter you
don't have reduce it's it's hard to do
branching and frameworks have solved
some of these problems that I've
mentioned but they're kind of hacking
around the idea that we want to pull
certain parts of our display logic apart
and artificially separate technologies
another symptom is if you're continually
inventing new concepts so JavaScript is
based on a rich history of Vonn demand
based programming model language aming
languages and has kind of battle-tested
philosophies right like we understand
how functions work it's very clear
prototypical inheritance most people
understand but when you start to build
abstractions on top of you know HTML you
start to have to invent a lot of things
in order to get to the level of
expressiveness you need to build real
applications so now I'm going to pick on
angular and I just pulled this this
quote out from the angular docs and I've
highlighted every concept that they've
created that I'm not I'm either not
really sure what it means as a new user
of angular or it sort of exists in
JavaScript and it's based on the idea
that they want to augment HTML to
support two-way data-binding and in
order to do that you have to rethink the
idea of scopes and if you think the idea
of scopes you have to rethink the idea
of composability
and modularity and you start building
directives and train
lucien and all this other stuff but i
think the framework cannot know how to
separate your concerns for you it should
only provide powerful and expressive
tools to let you do it
what I mean by that is that a lot of
frameworks force you into this MVC style
of development and MVC is great however
your controllers tend to get really fat
or maybe your models get really fat if
that's your style of building or maybe
even your views the reason for that is
the framework is telling you how to
separate your components and the
vocabulary you're speaking is that of
the framework and not of your
application so we want to change that
and we think the best tool for this is a
react component which is a highly
cohesive building block for you is
that's loosely coupled with other
components coupling and cohesion
constant theme here so we want you to
use components to separate your concerns
with the full power of JavaScript and
not a [ __ ] templating language so I'm
going to pull up that example I showed
earlier briefly and just highlight a
couple of things we wanted to reuse some
functionality so in react we created a
function which is how you reuse
functionality in JavaScript we wanted to
reuse um we wanted to reuse some code
and pass different parameters in each
time and have it render to the Dom so we
used composition and we composed a to-do
application out of a to-do list object
component again this is just regular
JavaScript software engineering
principles and we also have the full
expressive power of JavaScript so for
example I wanted to add 1/2 to the
length of this list when I render it I
didn't have to jump through any hoops I
just put a javascript expression in
there reusable components are great code
reuse we all we all we all can recognize
how awesome could reuse is composability
another big one you build the component
once you reuse it you can build more and
more complex components and it actually
you get kind of a linear increasing
complexity
then you know that giant curve of
complexity because you isolate your
complexity into separate components it's
kind of implied but these are unit
testable when you break your application
down into small units you can just unit
test them like you would unit test any
other piece of code you don't need some
sort of big you know test harness or
dependency injection framework unless
that's how you prefer to structure your
application so you're probably thinking
about spaghetti code right now I've
talked about mixing JavaScript
expressions in the Dom I've talked about
co-locating or display logic with it the
logic that generates the mark-up that
sounds like it's going to be a mess
right my answer to that is just don't
write spaghetti code
we're software engineers we can shoot
ourselves in the foot and I'm sure that
everybody's taken down something in
production before you can keep your
components small because we're trained
to do it we do it all the time with our
other JavaScript code why can't we do it
with our front end code only put display
logic in your components I'm not
advocating putting all of your your
model validation code and fetching and
data access in components you might want
to put them in third-party libraries
that have some sort of bridge to your
components but only put you know logic
that makes sense in your components and
this kind of reminds me of that
Spiderman quote that is always repeated
at software conferences with great power
comes great responsibility
another thing that people think about
when you're talking about generating DOM
and JavaScript is cross-site scripting
vulnerabilities so a lot of times people
do string concatenation to generate
markup and then insert that in the Dom
we've created a very lightweight library
that we call react Dom to make
generating a description of the Dom very
easily this is calling a method called a
which generates a link you pass your
JavaScript object of attributes in and
then a child which is the second
argument that can be you know other
react components other react Dom calls
strings collections that kind of thing
and this makes it really safe for us to
generate descriptions of the Dom the
next thing you're thinking about is
probably what about working with
designers
we're not the first people to come up
with the idea of generating Dom using
function calls but a lot of times it's a
little bit cumbersome to work with you
know we've actually found that if you're
just trying to balance parentheses
visually it can be kind of annoying to
do that and also designers tend to not
like that so we built JSX
which is an optional preprocessor it's a
syntax extension that lets you write
code that looks like this and translates
it into code that looks like that and
that's all it does we're not reinventing
a 4x there's no runtime that supports
this we're simply taking expressions
that look like HTML and turning them
into function calls so you get all the
semantics of JavaScript you get the same
line numbers as you would before the
transformation so you can actually run
your linting tools on your markup and
you know get all the same rich debugging
information that you otherwise would and
with JSX we've just found that it's very
easy for designers to contribute code I
personally don't want to spend hours
tweaking the box-shadow of all of my
elements I'd like to just have my
designer come in there and tweak them
for me and so we've actually had found
that this is very successful and we
think of it like this
it's the accessibility of templates and
the power of JavaScript the
accessibility of templates in the power
of JavaScript you can use all the
regular JavaScript code to generate
these because they're just function
calls but it looks kind of like markup
so you can go in there and kind of still
have your flow so react is all about
components and it's not about templates
and that's how we want you to separate
concerns so I'm going to talk to you
about what I think makes react awesome
and the key design decision that makes
react awesome is that we basically
rerender your entire app every on every
single data change we all know that
building UIs is hard and that's because
there's so much State you've got lots of
UI elements designers can't make up
their mind you ship one one version the
a/b test comes back and you want to ship
another one crazy environments if a dom
is up for a long time you may write to
the dom somewhere and forgot that you
wrote there and then
you know you forgot to keep track of it
and we've identified that data changing
over time is the root of all evil and
it's really hard for us as engineers to
reason about this and you know we're not
the first people that think this up
actually Dijkstra thought it up first
our intellectual powers are rather
geared to master static relations and
our powers to visualize processes
evolving in time are relatively poorly
developed what he's basically saying is
that it's really hard for us to think of
processes over time but it's fairly
straightforward for us to trace the flow
of a program he continues with for that
reason we should do our utmost to
shorten the conceptual gap between the
static program and the dynamic process
to make correspondence between the
program and the process as trivial as
possible now Dijkstra's advice is that
we should take processes that go over
time and build abstractions that make
them look like programs that execute in
a single point of time and that's what
it was like in the 90s when we were
building server rendered apps we hit the
database and we'd render a page and
let's say it's a you know a to-do list
example because that's the another theme
of this presentation I guess you render
the list of items and account and when
you submit another to-do item you just
select from the database again your
account and your list are up to date and
you just refresh the whole page very
simple we don't have any of these
problems with data being out of date and
stuff so when the data changes react
does this react tree renders the entire
component this basically makes it really
easy for you to think about what state
your application is in set another way
react components are just item potent
functions that describe your UI at any
point in time just like a server
rendered at again because they're just
functions that take some parameters and
output a description of the UI they're
very easy to unit test so here's a
here's a very brief example this is a
link that I can click and the count goes
up we've isolated the mutable state in a
get initial state method and we've
isolated all the state transitions in
state and set state methods and set
state is basically how you tell react
that the data has changed and it doesn't
matter where your data came from we've
done bindings for meteor that are 14
lines bindings for backbone that are 5
lines that kind of thing but you'll
notice that render describes how the UI
looks at any point in time so no where
do we look in the DOM and find where we
should update the count or where that
node lives or do we we don't even set up
a binding between the state variable and
the Dom and this is actually really
simple because it's so declarative every
place we display data is guaranteed to
be up-to-date and we do it without
magical data binding without dirty
checking the model which can be
expensive and of course this is a modern
framework there's no more explicit Dom
operations and everything is declarative
this seems like a pretty bad idea right
it'd be great if we could do all this
declarative work but re-rendering all of
the the dom nodes on your page is way
too expensive so we decided to build a
virtual Dom to make rear-ending on every
change fast you can't just throw at the
Dom so if I'm typing into a text field
and another piece of data updates I
don't want to lose what I'm typing into
the text field I don't want that flash
and reflow of my UI I don't want to use
lose my scroll position all that stuff
so what we did is we built this virtual
DOM and virtual event system that's
optimized for performance and memory
footprint so I'm just going to walk you
through how this works so on every
update which we get from that state that
set state call that I mentioned earlier
we build a new virtual dom subtree and
we dip it with the old one so if you
guys caught that talk on brackets
there'd actually doing similar things
with how we do the diffs we compute the
minimal set of dom mutations and we'd
like drop them into a queue and then we
back to execute all of the updates
together this looks a lot like the doom
3 engine there's a great series of blog
posts about how the doom 3 engine works
but you start with a game state and user
input so network events user input
events your knowledge of where everybody
is on the map what gun you have open you
know that kind of thing and then that
gets passed into the the front end of
the Dhoom 3 engine which executes the
game logic so there are scripts in the
levels there are certain rules about how
you can move throughout doom and that's
all in the front end and that creates an
intermediate representation of the scene
that intermediate representation gets
passed to the back end of the renderer
which generates the OpenGL operations
that then get flushed to the graphics
card here's how react works you have
your application state you have browser
events those go into your react
component tree which describes how your
application should work it's the
business logic of your application just
like the front-end of Doom three is a
business logic of Doom three we create
rather than a scene intermediate
representation we create a virtual Dom
which is an intermediate representation
of how your app should eventually look
we pass that to our back-end which
computes the operations that we need to
perform and then we flush those to the
Dom at the appropriate time and that's
actually pluggable how we flush it if
you want to use your own strategy you
can do that and this is actually
extremely fast primarily because most
Dom operations tend to be slow and
there's been a lot of performance work
on the Dom but you most operations tend
to drop frames because we can reason
about the global state of your
application at any point in time we can
compute the minimal set of Dom
operations and use heuristics to do
optimizations that reasoning about it at
a incremental level you can't and
because you're building components and
we enforce a strict life cycle on those
components we batch reads and writes for
the optimal performance so you're never
going to get in a situation where you do
a read do a write to the Dom then do a
read from the Dom again which triggers a
reflow now this is all stuff that you've
probably already heard about but
enforcing this at scale with a large
number of engineers building a large
number of components is actually
extremely difficult and react enforces
that for you and we found that this is
usually faster than manual Dom
operations
so react is not magic just like you can
drop into assembler with C and beat cm
beat the C compiler you can drop into
raw Dom operations and Dom API calls and
beat react if you wanted to
however using C or you know Java or
JavaScript is an order of magnitude
performance improvement because you
don't have to worry about you know in
Java or JavaScript managing memory and
in C you know the very specifics of the
platform and so with react you can build
applications without even thinking about
performance and the default state is
fast and we don't just stop at at you
know computing the minimal set of Dom
operations and making the Dom operations
fast we do automatic top-level event
delegation we basically re implemented
an event system so we have event
plug-ins that you know you can write
it's it's a pluggable part of our core
that read the raw stream of browser
events that come in and generate
synthetic events and these synthetic
events are compliant to the w3c
specification in all browsers and then
we have our own implementation of
bubbling and capturing which works
consistently across all browsers now we
have a great side effect of this which
is you get some cool html5 events in IE
8 for example because we have an
entirely synthetic event system another
thing about performance is we provide
some hooks to help you get even more
performance so there was a great talk
yesterday about two-way data-binding
performance and comparing and
contrasting the techniques and any sort
of automatic management of your UI
can be made to be slow if there's a
crazy enough example what makes react
special in this even though it's fast
out of the box
we provide optimisation hooks that don't
require you to refactor your application
to get speed boosts what this mean is
what this means is that you can write a
function that can tell react not to diff
a certain part of the tree and this is
this doesn't require you to change the
coupling between components rethink how
you fundamentally architected your app
and these hints to react are usually
just one line of code and we built demos
that run at 60 frames per second in non
JIT iPhone 5 web views and that's the
environment that a lot of you know
PhoneGap users would use the bottleneck
is almost never the diffing it's always
the Dom operations so the virtual Dom
let's just do some other cool things so
we can run in node.js so we're talking
about not breaking the web in the last
presentation and I think there was
mention of Google not crawling single
page applications that are all rendered
in JavaScript so what a lot of people
are doing today is they're running
phantom j/s they're running their
JavaScript and then they're dumping a
static HTML file and serving it to
Google what we do is we can actually
render an entirely static HTML page
without a Dom on the server so it's
actually really really fast and you can
serve all of your production traffic
with it so there's obvious C SEO
benefits here but we can do some other
cool things too you run the same code on
the client in the server and you send
down some markup react boots up on the
client and looks to see if markup is
there if the markup is there all it does
is attach event listeners and initialize
itself so you get a faster page load
experience your users will get the speed
and of being able to interact with a you
know static HTML page and by the time
the JavaScript is downloaded the
interactivity will pop in for you so you
can imagine the first page load
experience is a static page you start
typing a comment in a comment box and by
the time you're done typing the comment
and you press submit the JavaScript is
loaded in the background and you're
ready to go it's completely seamless
there's some other cool things we can do
because you're building components that
separate your concerns and represent
your application structure we have
knowledge of what your application looks
like and what it's going to do so your
components tend to reflect the structure
of your application and the information
architecture of the UI you're showing so
we can say you know hey if the if a
large subset of this virtual
representation
about to change maybe we should use a
different method of emptying dom nodes
than one for a smaller subset of the of
the dom and this is something that you
can't do just with dom manipulation and
finally testability for free I mentioned
before that these are just idempotent
components that take in some data and
output a description of the DOM and it's
a description of the Dom so you don't
actually have to run a s DOM or phantom
j/s to test your components you can if
you want and there are some useful use
cases for actually testing in a real
engine but you can just pass in some
data and then assert what your component
returned from its render method it's
very fast and you don't need a set of a
convoluted test environment for it a
week or two ago we also open source
SVG vml and canvas support via our
bindings to the art library we think
that you should be able to render your
interactive charts in the same
declarative way that you render your
interactive UI on the same you just
create a component that renders to a
canvas instead of to the DOM and finally
we have an experimental branch that
renders your whole app in a webworker
I'm not sure that this is a great idea
but the point is when you have a virtual
Dom representation you're not tied to
the browser you can run anywhere in any
sort of environment and it's extremely
valuable and while this was kind of a
cool hack it wasn't really that much
work to do we just send the events over
the boundary into the web worker and it
sends Dom operations back over to the
web worker like I said not sure this is
a great idea but it has some cool
implications so let's talk about the key
takeaways that I just mentioned I want
you to build components not templates
because I want you to separate your
concerns in the language of your
application not in the language of the
framework it's really hard to think
about mutation so just throw out your
old application re render the whole
thing and then have the implementation
take care of it for you and that
implementation is a virtual DOM and it's
actually not very complicated
extremely fast thanks to the great
JavaScript engines we have today so with
that I'd like to say thanks to Jay s
Khan for having me that's it
you